(audience applauds)
- Welcome back, y'all.
Dan Levy is hanging out with us!
(audience cheers)
His new Netflix movie
is called "Good Grief."
It's about a man who goes
to Paris with his friends
after a big life event.
Paris can be very therapeutic.
Some great movies and shows are set there.
So this is a game
celebrating all of those,
as well as Dan's movie.
It is called, get Ready America,
"Viens Avec Moi a Paris Cesoir."
(audience laughs)
(French music)
♪ Viens Avec Moi a Paris Cesoir. ♪
- Go ahead, Jessie!
(audience laughs)
Go ahead.
(Kelly speaks French)
(audience applauds)
♪ Ooh ooh ♪
(audience cheers)
- I'm really competitive.
- Okay, me too, me too.
- [God] Bonjour From above, Kelly and Dan.
- Ooh!
- [God] I am here for you. (speaks French)
- Yeah, God, God got sexy, okay.
- [God] I got it.
That's right.
I made up all the languages, girl.
I know what's going on.
(Kelly laughs)
Okay, now in this game,
I'm gonna give you a clue
about a movie or a show that was set
or at least partially set in Paris.
All you have to do is hit your button
and give me the answer.
But just like half of the artwork
in the Louvre steals are allowed.
(audience laughs)
That's a Napoleon joke.
Okay, here we go.
(Kelly gasps)
Here's your first clue:
- Oh, my God.
I was thinking of the
game I didn't hear...
- [God] Give it a minute.
- I got it.
- [God] Here's your first one.
This movie all built up
to Fashion Week in Paris.
(buzzer beeps)
- "Devil Wears Prada."
(bell dings)
(audience applauds)
- It is
"The Devil Wears Prada."
Kelly, you got yourself a point.
- Such a great movie.
- I was going to the Robert Altman film,
(Kelly laughs)
Pret-a-Porter,
which was off-key.
- She's one stomach flu
away from the perfect size.
I love that movie.
- Great movie.
Fabulous movie.
- [God] The Devil may wear Prada,
but God always wears Christian Dior.
- Yeah!
(audience laughs)
Alright, God
- [God] Or Armani.
It is a better cut.
Armani's abetter cut.
Here's your next question.
It was a young rodents
dream to be a world-
- Ooh, I-
(buzzer beeps)
- [God] Dan.
- "Ratatouille"
(bell dings)
- It is "Ratatouille."
(audience applauds)
- My kids love that one.
That was quick!
(audience applauds)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Fine, I see you.
I'm just warming up.
- I see you.
Okay.
- [God] There you go, Dan.
There's that competitive spirit.
(Dan laughs)
You on the board now.
We got a tie, so here's your next clue:
I dreamed a dream that
the cast of this musical-
(buzzer beeps)
- Oh, (beep).
- "Les Mis."
(audience laughs)
(bell dings)
- It is "Les Mis."
(audience applauds)
You are fierce, you are fierce.
- I'm disappointed.
(Dan laughs)
I'm disappointed in myself.
- [God] That's the one where
Gladiator and Wolverine
were singing show tunes.
(Kelly laughs)
- That's exactly it.
- [God] Here's your next clue:
We're back to Meryl Streep here.
Now here in a film that followed
a young
(buzzer beeps)
- Oh, I knew-
- "Julie and Julia."
(bell dings)
- Unbelievable.
- That's not fair.
(audience cheers)
- [God] That's two points
right there.
- I was ready for that one!
(audience applauds)
- [God] Yep!
- I thought you had to ask the question.
Fine, Dan, it's on!
- [God] Yep.
Look at her-
- Fine!
- getting all worked up.
Here's your next clue:
In this Netflix show,
the daughter of Phil Collins moved
from Chicago-
(buzzer beeps)
Dan.
(audience laughs)
- "Emily in Paris."
(bell dings)
- It's is "Emily in Paris."
(audience cheers)
It is a miracle.
(audience applauds)
- I knew that one.
- You know what is?
- You're so fast!
- I know, I'm gonna give you a clue.
There is so much of the answer
already in the question.
- I know.
(audience laughs)
- [God] Oh, he's good.
Oh, he's good.
- All right,
Tips McGee, alright.
- [God] Oh, he is good.
- [Kelly] I'm gonna bury you.
- [God] Mm, okay.
- I probably won't.
(Dan coughs)
- [God] Here's your next clue.
Maybe you could get some points
on the board there, Kelly.
- Oh, my gosh.
(audience laughs)
- [God] Exactly.
The series finale to this show
(buzzer beeps)
found Kerry-
(audience laughs)
- "Sex in the City!"
- [God] Dan.
(bell dings)
- It is "Sex in the City."
(audience cheers)
- [God] It's so sad that
you're losing, Kelly.
I'm sorry.
I can't.
Don't hate me.
- I hear your tone.
- Anyway.
- [God] This thriller of a movie
found Tom Hanks traveling all over Paris.
(buzzer beeps)
- "Da Vinci Code."
(bell dings)
(audience cheers)
- "The DaVinci Code."
- I know that one!
(horn sounds)
- [God] Well, that sound means
it's almost time to leave Paree.
We've got time for one more question.
- Oh, can't wait.
- And this one
is for all the je ne sais quoi.
Are you ready?
We'll make this 50 points.
Why not?
(Dan chuckles)
- What?
- [God] This Baz Luhrmann
film had a British poet-
(buzzer beeps)
- "Moulin Rouge!"
(bell dings)
- [God] It is "Moulin Rouge."
(audience applauds)
(horn sounds)
(audience cheers)
- Of all the good answers!
- And the winner is-
- Kelly Clarkson.
(audience applauds)
- Kelly has won.
- I was like-
- [Dan] Oh, my gosh.
- I kind of feel bad,
but that that last one
was worth so many points-
- 50 points.
- 'cause you
definitely beat me!
You definitely beat me!
Remember to check...
I won.
Remember to check out Dan's new movie.
I didn't really win.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But I lose like that a lot on this show.
- I did feel bad for a minute.
I was really-
- I felt bad for me, I know.
- I don't want that here.
- You killed me.
If there's a game night to be had,
I wanna be on your team.
(Dan laughs)
Remember to check out Dan's new movie.
It's called "Good Grief,"
and it's on Netflix.